the uk's chief scientific adviser who
joins us from westminster good morning
to you me the big question here is why
the advice that is being given to our
government does seem to be different to
the advice being given to many other
governments who are taking much more
stringent action well we've got a panel
of a very world leading scientists
across epidemiology mathematical
modelling viral OG clinicians and we're
taking input from leading academics to
come try and come up with a plan that
actually does what we want it to do and
it doesn't mean that the others are
doing something wrong and in fact much
of the advice and much of the actions if
you look at them they're trying to
achieve the same thing and that is to
try to reduce the peak of the epidemic
flatten it and broaden it so that you
don't end up with so much intense
pressure on healthcare systems at one
time so that's one aim is to reduce
transmission try to make sure that we
end up with a broader epidemic not a
very sharp one that overloads the system
and the second of course is to protect
the elderly and vulnerable and to make
sure that during that peak they are
protected as well as you can because
that's the group that stand the biggest
chance of having a serious outcome from
this many people are asking the question
and it has to be legitimate as to why if
you're trying to delay the spread of the
virus and people can understand why you
would want to do that while we basically
seem to be allowing society to continue
as normal you know that there's no
lockdowns there's no shutdowns of
schools or education facilities there's
still people going to restaurants and
the theater isn't that actually being
gonna be problematic in terms of trying
to delay the spread of the virus so the
UK is actually done a good job of
contact tracing and isolating so the
first phase of this means that we've a
little bit behind we in terms of where
the outbreak is compared to others and
the measures that were announced which
is about self isolation even if you've
got very mild symptoms will mean a large
number of people actually at home
being isolated because of this infection
that's a very big measure actually it's
going to have quite a big impact across
a number of households a number of
people so I don't think that's a trivial
measure it's all and all the modeling
suggests that these sorts of measures
and the other two that we discussed
yesterday the ones that have the biggest
impact there are other things which
you're quite right of things that do
have some effect and and come in at the
right time and mass gatherings is the
one that keeps coming up and mass
gatherings of course are a place where
you can potentially get infection from
somebody but the alternative is also
important that if you're not at the mass
gathering you're at a small gathering
and most of the transmission of these
types of viruses occur in small
gatherings not in big gatherings and
therefore this concentration on getting
people who got symptoms into their house
isolated potentially the next step to
last households to do it so you contain
the whole thing in a household and
making sure we protect the vulnerable
and elderly are the first three things
we need to do doesn't cause stop the
possibility that even relatively soon
you need to do more than that but
getting this right and making sure that
we can monitor the outbreak is
absolutely key you talk about the
modeling Jeremy Hunt the former health
secretary last night was talking about
the modeling saying he would like to see
if modeling particularly better
behavioral science which he seemed to
imply was taking some sort of precedence
over the epidemiology oh I don't think
that's correct I mean I I think the
modeling and the behavioral science and
the clinical input come together it's
not absolutely not the case that
behavioral science takes a predominance
but of course it's an important
consideration and it is the case of
course that if you completely locked
down absolutely everything probably for
a period of four months or more then you
would suppress this virus all of the
evidence from previous epidemics
suggests that when you do that and then
you release it it all comes back again
so the other part of this is to make
sure that we don't end up with a sudden
peak again in the winter which is even
larger which causes even more problem
so we want to suppress it not get rid of
it completely which you can't do anyway
not suppress it so we get the second
peek and also allowing us enough of us
who are going to get mild illness to
become immune to this to help with the
sort of whole population response which
would protect everybody yeah I mean that
that herd immunity I know you talked
about yesterday
when you were appearing with the prime
minister and in terms of building up a
herd immunity within the UK well I mean
what sort of percentage of people need
to have contracted the virus probably
about 60% or so and we think that this
virus is likely to be one that comes
back year-on-year become like a seasonal
virus and communities will become immune
to it and that's going to be an
important part of controlling this
longer term sixty percent sixty percent
is the sort of figure you need to get
hurt mmunity I mean even without even
looking at the sort of the best-case
scenario and I were talking last week
and you were saying you know half of one
percent to one percent
fatality in something like this that's
an awful lot of people dying in this
country well I mean of course we do face
the prospect of as the Prime Minister
said yesterday of an increasing number
of people dying that is a real prospect
this is a nasty disease for most people
it's a mild disease it's important to
know we don't know yet nobody knows what
proportion of people have this who are
completely asymptomatic so the only
cases that we've really got at the
moment are people who've had symptoms or
largely people who've had symptoms that
means that even estimating exactly what
the death rate is from this is quite
difficult because there may be many more
people that haven't been detected yet
and that's why some of the new tests
that are being developed now going to be
so important so we can really understand
how this disease is spreading and we
don't have a handle on that yet in terms
of our response so there's a couple of
points I want to put to you one the
former Prime Minister of Italy was
talking to Sky News yesterday you said
yesterday we're about four week
behind Italy don't you want to avoid
being like Italy and their former
prime-minister saying don't repeat our
mistakes don't waste time yes it should
we not heed some of that advice I think
I think my comments about being behind
Italy about where we were on the the
unmitigated curve of the epidemic we've
been working on this since the beginning
of January so this isn't something that
suddenly groups have come together to
think about yesterday this is a group of
people that have been working very hard
on this giving advice over the whole
time what we don't want to do is to get
into knee-jerk reactions where you have
to start doing measures at the wrong
pace because something's happened so
we're trying to keep ahead of it we're
trying to lay out the path so people can
see what the actions are that are being
advised and then of course it's up to
ministers to decide which of those
actions are the most appropriate to take
so I completely agree with the Prime
Minister of Italy you do not want to be
caught on the back foot on this
professor professor John Ashton who I'm
sure you know former director of public
health England for the Northwest region
he said the response so far has been
wooden an academic well I think John
will have his views on this and they're
perfectly legitimate lots of people have
got views on this I think that what
we're trying to do is feed in the most
up-to-date and relevant advice we can to
enable sensible decisions to be made at
the right time and of course during this
sort of thing there are lots of people
lots of different voices coming from all
sorts of angles and if you listen to all
of them they are largely mutually
incompatible so it's impossible to keep
everybody happy with any response you do
and that's why we're trying to base it
on the best possible advice and actually
the whole point is that this is very
practical advice based on the science
not something that actually is meant to
be an academic exercise at all oh it's a
Patrick you have the advantage of not
being a politician although I know you
don't get to have the final say in all
of this but are you prepared if this
changes if you look back at this in a
week and say you know what this hasn't
been the right action how flexible are
you prepared to be in changing your
position in your advice to the
government
absolutely I will base it on the
evidence and my job as chief scientific
advisor is to is to speak scientific
truth to power and say it as it is and
that's exactly what I will do